we've got a remarkable story today and
remarkable is a word here of
perseverance in the face of great
injustice
joyce watkins spent decades in prison
for a crime she did not commit because
of bad science a former boyfriend also
wrongly convicted died in prison
according to the innocence project false
or misleading forensic evidence is a
factor in nearly a quarter of all
wrongful convictions in this country
aaron moriarty is here with this
particular story erin this is just
heartbreaking on many levels but it was
an honor to meet joyce what happened to
joyce watkins and her boyfriend charlie
dunn is scary because it could happen to
anyone hundreds of people have been
convicted because of so-called forensic
sciences that are later discredited and
as you will see in this case it's an
error that can take years or even a
lifetime to correct
my family is my life my niece is my
nephew that's my life
late on the night of june 26 1987
joyce watkins drove from her home in
tennessee to pick up her great niece who
had been staying with a relative in
kentucky for two months
almost immediately watkins could tell
something was wrong
and took the child in the morning to the
emergency room the four-year-old seen
here as she was transferred to
vanderbilt medical center in nashville
was suffering from head and vaginal
injuries and died a day later
joyce did it ever occur to you at that
moment that you would be
accused of her death
no
but they questioned you yes
they asked me what happened to her i
told him i didn't know
i couldn't tell them something that i
didn't know because i don't know
despite evidence that the child had been
injured while in kentucky watkins and
her boyfriend charlie dunn became
suspects after an assistant medical
examiner visually observing the child's
bruises mistakenly determined that she
had been injured during the nine hours
she was with the couple everybody just
got laser focused on joyce and charlie
jason gitchner is a senior attorney with
the tennessee innocence project it
didn't matter that
they cooperated with the investigation
that they kept meeting with the police
over and over again without a lawyer and
saying we didn't do this come take
whatever evidence you want watkins and
dunn were both convicted and sent to
prison for life it took everything away
from us
it took us from our families
him from his kids
took us from
everything we worked for
over the years they tried and failed to
get their convictions overturned in 2015
while still incarcerated charlie dunn
died of throw cancer later that year
after 27 years in prison watkins was
released on parole what was your mission
at that point
to prove our innocence last summer the
conviction review unit of the davidson
county district attorney's office
released a report finding that the
methods used by the medical examiner
have been largely discredited and
determined that joyce watkins and
charlie dunn are actually innocent when
you
heard at the hearing last december just
how wrong her medical evidence was in
1987 and that it was
the main evidence against you and
charlie how did you feel about that
broken real heartbroken
because it's something that should have
never happened
that was when i was incarcerated it took
35 years and the unwavering faith of
joyce watkins now 74 years old but in
january of this year the court finally
got it right
miss watkins this
charge against you is dismissed
and to the family of
charlie dunn the charge against charlie
dunn is dismissed it was a happy day
it was a happy day
but bittersweet too
you never got to grieve either you never
had time to grieve the loss of brandy no
i haven't
but
i'm going to go and visit her grave
in a few months
both joyce watkins and charlie dunn lost
everything they had under tennessee law
joyce has to first apply for and then
get a pardon from the governor to be
eligible for any compensation and
there's likely nothing for the family of
charlie dunn i think the real takeaway
on this story is the fact that there was
too much weight put on one witness that
assistant medical examiner because they
ignored all the evidence that this child
had had problems in kentucky before
joyce and charlie ever pick them up but
i'm looking at joyce who lost such a big
chunk of her life charlie who is no
longer with us will they reopen the
investigation because somebody did
something to this little girl and it
wasn't them i think there is a demand
for that but it has been 35 years and so
you know witnesses are gone um i think
it could be very very difficult
um you told us just before we went on
there she was in the process of adopting
a child herself i think so she lost many
things she did you know she owned her
own home and she had savings but i think
what hurts her the most is the fact that
she was in the process of adopting a
child she's all about family and i think
that's what weighs on her the most the
biggest loss and that can't be
compensated for what was she like uh
aaron well i have to i'm in awe of her i
the word grace comes to mind every time
when you everyone says that when they
meet her she doesn't appear to have
anger um she is just determined and and
here's what i loved about her the most
that it wasn't enough for her to be
exonerated even though charlie had gone
she insisted he'd be exonerated as well
wow and and you pointed out yesterday
aaron the killer killers still at large
abs well have never been if someone
killed her and they don't think these
injuries are accidental that person has
never been brought to justice no
question uh tough story aaron
compensation here though erin that's
that's that strikes me too no
compensation no well under the law she
has to get a pardon first she has to get
a pardon first and then it's limited to
a million which may sound like a lot but
it's not considering all that she lost
yeah it's not erin thank you very much